♪ (PLAYING PIANO) ♪
Oh, yeah.
I got some sound now.
One, two.
HOWARD STERN: Bruce Springsteen
is a few inches away from me.
And I am-- I'm starstruck.
(LAUGHS)
STERN: We have
so many questions,
-so let me just dive in.
-Sounds great.
I love what you say
about your dad.
-Boy, do I relate to that.
-Yeah.
It was tough. My role model,
my father, was not giving.
♪ I was born blue
And weathered ♪
All I knew is,
I am his agent in the world,
and I'm going to make something
out of your story.
A lot of my work,
if not most of it,
that's the root of it.
♪ (STRUMMING GUITAR) ♪
STERN: So, you're sitting there
with Clarence.
-Yeah.
-STERN: Do I have it right?
You were sitting
and strumming the guitar?
That was tough.
I had a feeling he could hear me
because he could squeeze
your hand.
So I just played this song.
♪ Oh, meet me ♪
♪ In a land of hope
And dreams ♪
STERN: Beautiful song.
It's-- Yeah, it's a hymn.
You have any tricks
in songwriting?
First thing you want
is a good metaphor.
♪ (PLAYING PIANO) ♪
I'm playing and I'm singing,
but I'm listening too.
If I'm creating that sensation
for me,
I know I'm creating it for you.
♪ Oh, Thunder Road ♪
♪ Sit tight, take hold ♪
♪ Thunder Road ♪
Finally got me to cry
on the air.
It's the first time ever.
-(CHUCKLES)
-STERN: Wow.